[Music]
on this Friday night cartel violence
leaves Canadians stranded in Mexico
normally this street is extremely busy
ottawa's warning for travelers as deadly
clashes shut down a tourist hot spot we
cannot get to the airport from where we
are an unexpected jaw boom brings
Canadians economic hope but persistent
worker shortages still linger could
immigration be the answer it is probably
our best tool for increasing the size of
the labor market the search for scammers
who sold a Toronto home without consent
how covid may have helped pull off the
massive mortgage fraud plus buzzing over
a new vaccine we need to have solutions
that are non-chemical that are tested
that are safe the world first that has
Canadian researchers looking for new
ways to protect an agricultural
Workforce
global national we althy with para
Nasser
good evening
Canadian snowbirds and vacationers in
Western Mexico are trying to figure out
what's next and whether they can or
should come home
the high profile arrest of a drug lord
who is the son of drug kingpin El Chapo
has led to an explosion of violence in
the past 24 hours
shots have been fired trucks set on fire
mostly in culiacan the home base at the
Sinaloa cartel located two hours north
of Mazatlan a popular vacation spot
WestJet and sun wing have now canceled a
number of flights in and out of Mazatlan
as it waits for the situation to
stabilize as Heather York's West reports
in our top story tonight Canadians who
are now trapped in the region are
frightened and figuring out a way to
come home
with beautiful beaches and the promise
of sun it's no wonder thousands of
Canadians flock to Mexico every winter
Justin noga knew it would be the perfect
place to propose we've been here since
Saturday
um we're actually here uh we got engaged
on uh
Sunday but Noka and his fiance were
forced to stop celebrating and start
Sheltering when cartel violence gripped
the region the cities were actually very
much affected there were a lot of
disruptions we did not expect that level
of disruption going forward but it is
worth keeping in mind that situations
may occur
in the cinema city of culiacon burning
buses blocked roads and an Aero Mexico
plane was hit by gunfire Thursday after
the arrest of Mexican drug cartel leader
ovidio Guzman son of the infamous El
Chapo they just basically shut the city
down
and took every precaution to make sure
that there was no problems within
Mazatlan three airports including
Mazatlan International were closed as
well putting travel plans for many on
hold we don't want to go there we just
wanted to rebook our flight somewhere
else we don't feel safe going there but
we have had zero information from the
airline by Friday Global Affairs Canada
announced that the Mazatlan and
couliacan Airport had reopened and while
an advisory warning against all
non-essential travel remains in place
Security Experts believe the threat is
likely over for now the cartels really
don't have a vested interest in going
after Canadians or Americans or other
expats certainly Sheltering in place
while you had the violence there it was
a very wise move uh but one thing once
things settle down it should go back to
kind of that that normal pattern and the
normal concerns I think everything is
kind of seems like it's opening up and
the transportation is back though many
Travelers including Justin and his
fiancee are still waiting for word on
how they'll get home we want to get back
to our families after a tense reminder
that this piece of paradise is not
without risk either York's West Global
News Calgary
severe flooding has hit parts of
California's Coast as another storm
moves in it's part of a series of bomb
Cyclones and Atmospheric rivers that are
prompting evacuation warnings in
low-lying cities like Santa Cruz crews
are racing to restore power to tens of
thousands of people before the next
storm moves in heavy rain is forecast
through Sunday mudslides are now a worry
after repeated downpours and past
wildfires have stripped hillsides of
vegetation
Canada started the new year with some
good news on the economy after closing
out 2022 with a big boost in job numbers
according to statistics Canada the
country added 104 000 more jobs in
December slightly dropping the national
unemployment rate down to five percent
that's a hair above the record set in
June of last year Mackenzie gray breaks
down the new numbers and why they might
actually not be as helpful as the cost
of living increases
in turbulent Economic Times the Canadian
labor market is defying expectations the
latest jobs numbers coming in over 20
times higher than expected so far we're
entering into the new year in probably
the strongest position that we could be
hoping for 84 000 of the new jobs were
full-time and created almost exclusively
in the private sector construction led
the way with 35 000 new workers
Transportation a close second Healthcare
suffered the largest drop with 17 000
workers leaving an already struggling
system despite the big gains the numbers
of hours worked actually stayed flat the
culprit the triple threat of covid RSV
in the flu leaving 8.1 percent of
workers needing days off it's entirely
possible that some businesses are having
to go and hire extra people because so
many are are basically calling in sick I
I think that likely played a role wages
are up for the seven consecutive month
but they still lag behind red-hot
inflation the surprise report flies in
the face of what the Bank of Canada had
expected would happen in recent months
we've seen initial signs of these
exceptionally tight labor markets
starting to ease that puts Tiff Macklin
in a difficult position the bank is
trying to tame inflation by slowing down
the economy but the hot jobs Market has
[ __ ] CIBC and Desjardins all predicting
the Bank of Canada will increase rates
later this month by 25 basis points
bringing their key rate to 4.5 percent
the fact that the Canadian economy is
historically sensitive to interest rates
interest rates are high that'll weigh on
consumers it'll weigh on borrowers and
will continue to see the impacts of a
softer housing market work their way
through the broader economy another high
quid put more pressure on an already
declining housing market and make it
more difficult for Canadians who are set
to renew their mortgages we definitely
hear
the words I'm going to need to sell my
house from some people today's report
has left some economists believing
Canada could pull off a so-called soft
Landing where inflation drops to
pre-covered levels but we don't head
into a recession however Farah most are
still betting on a mild recession later
this year
okay Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you
for that
despite the growth in jobs last month
there's data that highlights the
persistent labor shortages in this
country employees across all industries
were still looking to fill nearly 960
000 vacant job positions across Canada
that's according to a statistics Canada
report released last month and at the
same time the country also welcomed a
record number of new immigrants last
year and as tariya Israel reports they
may be the key to filling the most
crucial job openings
for immigrants arriving in Canada the
first steps can be uncertain but Jihan
shliha laid the groundwork early I tried
to prepare my my arrival to Canada much
before the 35 year old I.T specialist
moved from Morocco to Ottawa at the
start of the pandemic I could land my
first job like about two months after I
landed here so that was apparently it's
a record
Canada set its own record last year
welcoming more than 430 000 new
permanent residents hugely significant
it shows you know the government's plan
to bring really record numbers of
immigrants has been working the
government is boosting immigration
levels as part of its strategy to fill
significant worker shortages it's not a
magic pill it doesn't solve everything
but it is probably our best tool for
increasing the size of the labor market
over time most newcomers land in big
cities and while many find jobs waiting
for them immediate affordable housing is
often Out Of Reach I think there is a
crisis like there isn't enough
um like we want more people to come but
we don't have where to host it a recent
report from the Canada mortgage and
housing Corporation found the country
needs to build an additional three and a
half million homes by 2030 to make life
more affordable I don't think the
solution to our housing challenges is to
shut the door to newcomers I think it's
to build more houses we don't bring in
very many immigrants who work in trades
and construction comparatively and
compared to other countries so if we did
more of that we may be able to address
some of those labor shortages
ottawa's plan for the new year is to
prioritize specific sectors the health
sector the care sector construction and
tourism all the areas where we know this
this skill shortages and people don't
necessarily have to have a master's
degree whatever the job one thing is
universal resettling in a new country is
rarely easy change is not easy but it's
it's refreshing especially for those
embracing change in challenging times
Global News Ottawa
and embracing the snow the U.S jobs
report was also out today and it was
also positive employers there added 223
000 jobs in December but there is one
job that just can't seem to be filled
speaker off the house American lawmakers
are in for a late night as they
desperately try to reach a deal on the
fourth day of voting Republican leader
Kevin McCarthy faces stubborn opposition
from within his own party our Washington
bureau chief Jackson prosco joins us now
Jackson where did things stand
far the results of two more rounds of
voting today suggest that things may
finally be starting to shift Kevin
McCarthy was able to sway 15 of the 21
holdouts opposed to his leadership but
his remaining opponents still have
enough votes to block his bid for
speaker so they've decided to adjourn
until 10 pm local time tonight in hopes
that they can get two more Republican
lawmakers back into town who'd been
unable to vote and sway at least two of
those remaining holdouts it's all a bit
of a long shot but at this point it's
also McCarthy's only shot and he
genuinely believes he will be speaker
before the night is over now to get this
far McCarthy has had to make major
concessions to the far right wing of the
Republican party which could ultimately
make it very hard for him to keep the
support of the moderates he will need if
he actually wants to get things done
among the things the so-called Freedom
caucus is asking for are cuts to defense
spending and Social Security they also
want McCarthy to change the rules of the
house so that a single member can see to
oust him as speaker at any point in time
all of this is to say that even if
McCarthy does lock up his bid tonight
his time as speaker will all but
certainly be Rocky and his grip on power
will be tenuous pharah certainly Jackson
Brosco in Washington thank you Jackson
President Biden has presented America's
second highest civilian award to 14
people who helped defend against the
attack on the capitol two years ago
today
Biden paid tribute to their heroism
saying they did not flinch as they
defended democracy among the recipients
were election workers and members of law
enforcement including Capitol Police
Officer Brian sicknick who died a day
after supporters of Donald Trump stormed
the building Biden says the violence was
fueled by lies about the 2020
presidential election
Russia's proposed ceasefire does not
appear to be quelling the violence in
Ukraine President Vladimir Putin has
said he wants both sides to stop
fighting for Orthodox Christmas but
Ukrainian president velodimir zielinski
hasn't agreed he says it's just a ploy
to give Russian troops an advantage on
the battlefield
some people spent today in bomb shelters
as Christmas festivities began in leviv
children sang carols as they sheltered
from Air Raid Sirens each side is
accusing the other of breaking the truce
as Redmond Shannon reports it comes the
same day Ukraine gets a huge boost of
military aid
a holiday of Peace in a country at War
soldiers marking the eve of the
traditional date of Ukrainian Orthodox
Christmas
the head of Ukraine's Orthodox Church
prays for victory on the battlefield
the donbass the fight goes on under the
Yuletide snow
brain rejected Vladimir Putin's proposal
of a 36-hour ceasefire for what is also
Russian Orthodox Christmas these
Ukrainian troops say that was just a
scam
we don't trust them what ceasefire can
you hear that said this Soldier
Moscow however claimed all of its forces
down to their weapons at noon local time
on Friday
Ukraine says just before the ceasefire
was supposed to come into effect Russian
shelling on a fire station killed one
rescue worker in her song welcome yes
sir Keith President Vladimir zielinski
met with U.S senators Jack Reed and
Angus King thank you very much for
for everything their visit time to
coincide with Washington's announcement
of a huge Aid package gimlers Rockets
surfaced to air missiles as well
anti-vehicle landmines ammunition in all
more than 3 billion US dollars worth of
military assistance for Ukraine the
largest such package yet coming on a
week when France and Germany also
donated defense missiles and military
vehicles to Ukraine
meanwhile Vladimir Putin's closest
foreign Ally met with Russian soldiers
Belarus leader Alexander lukashenka
speaking to Kremlin troops stationed in
his country for a joint exercise
raising fears Russia May again use
Belarus as a staging post to attack
Ukraine as it did last February Redmond
Shannon Global News London
a nightmare Homecoming coming out the
brazy fraud the left to Toronto couple
without a home
to a bizarre case of real estate fraud
the owners of a Toronto area home were
away on a business trip abroad they came
home to find out that two people
impersonated them and their house had
been sold behind their backs Kayla
McLean on the crime and the alleged
culprits
it was January 2022 as fewer properties
were being listed and market conditions
were tightening in the GTA this is when
police say Toronto homeowners away on a
business trip discovered their home was
sold without their consent or knowledge
Toronto police are now looking for these
two people they allege pretended to be
the homeowners hired a real estate agent
and listed the Etobicoke property for
sale the home sold to new owners who
took possession investigators say the
legitimate owners never found out their
property had been sold until several
months later so how can something like
this happen this real estate expert says
it may be more common than one might
think somewhere along the way a person
with access to the land or registry
system whether it's a lawyer or another
person transferred the title from the
present homeowners to someone else
illegally that land registry system
Ronald fonso says is administered and
owned by taranet on behalf of the
Ontario government real estate lawyers
and others who are authorized to
transfer titles and sell houses have
access to it through specific key codes
their key code is
taken by somebody else or copied by
somebody else or misappropriated in some
way that person has access to the system
and can do whatever they want they can
transfer one house or a hundred houses
and Alfonso says thanks to coveted
precautions this type of fraud is
relatively easy to pull off pre-covet
clients need to go to a lawyer's office
when buying a home to sign documents
answer questions and present ID now you
can do what is called DocuSign or
electronic signing online you can easily
go into Photoshop
just copy a passport change a picture
here and there the lawyer is going to
accept them at face value in the
Etobicoke case police have not released
the names of the accused just these two
photos Global News reached out for more
information but police remaining
tight-lipped only directed all queries
back to the release as for how
homeowners and buyers can protect
themselves against this type of fraud
purchase title insurance
that protects the buyer against fraud
illegal transfer of title a whole range
of items Kayla McLean Global News
[Music]
explosive eruptions ahead the Hawaiian
volcanoes spewing lava once again
one of the world's most active volcanoes
is erupting again in Hawaii lava is
flooding the crater at kilauea's Summit
covering about 120 hectares it's not
threatening surrounding communities but
officials are monitoring high levels of
hazardous volcanic gas
Buffalo Bill's safety Demar Hamlin is
now breathing on his own for the first
time since his cardiac arrest
doctors have removed his ventilator the
24 year old is talking and he even
joined an emotional team meeting on
FaceTime today the number three has now
been spray painted on the Bill's home
turf and the team will wear a special
patch during Sunday's game Hamlin
collapsed on the field during Monday's
game
[Music]
Team Canada has done it again at the
world junior hockey championship winning
the gold medal game against checkia
Canada was up two nothing entering the
third period but the checks scored twice
in under a minute to tie it up late
Dylan Gunther scored the Golden Goal in
overtime to seal it for the Canadiens
and the budding star Connor Bedard was
named tournament MVP
protecting pollination next the new
vaccine making a buzz in the bee
industry
[Music]
let's talk about bees apart from making
honey they're essential to pollination
and according to statistics Canada bees
contribute over three billion dollars to
the agricultural industry every year but
they just like us humans can get sick so
a new vaccine in the U.S has beekeepers
very excited and as Mike drolets there's
an exciting Canadian development too
they're the Workhorse of the
Agricultural world doing double duty
pollinating crops and making honey far
less known is how susceptible bees are
to disease last winter 45 percent of the
colonies in Canada were lost the main
culprits varroa mites and the bacterial
disease called foul brood since the dawn
of humans keeping bees we've had foul
brood basically fell brood attacks and
kills larva as they hatch the bacteria
spores can also lay dormant for decades
making it difficult to catch
and the only sure way to get rid of it
is to burn the entire colony which can
have disastrous consequences if those
colonies have to be destroyed at the
wrong time it can have uh the the it has
a very large multiplier effect on the
total agricultural output of that uh
area breeding disease resistant bees and
testing alternative treatments is
constantly on the mind of Leonard Foster
and his team at the University of
British Columbia the problem with using
antibiotics to treat foul Broody says is
twofold bees are becoming immune and
antibiotics leave a residue in Honey
which is why the industry is buzzing
about the first vaccine developed for
honeybees being approved for use in the
U.S we need to have solutions that are
non-chemical and that uh not dangerous
for the environment that are tested that
are safe that are manufacture to the
highest level of Purity all of those
things and that was our mission the
approval process in Canada she says will
begin soon and could end up on the desk
of agri-food research scientist Steve
Purnell in Alberta but Pernell is also
working on a treatment for an even
bigger past the varroa might a made in
Canada solution that has already seen
positive results in the field we
constantly have to find alternative so
this would be a new alternative but it
would be a very different one chemically
than what's currently out there so so uh
you know I think there's lots of
potential for this to be adopted by the
beekeeping industry it's potentially a
double dose of good news for Canada's
800 000 bee colonies and keeping them
healthy Keeps Us fed micro light Global
News Toronto
and that's global national for this
Friday night I'm Farah Nasser and your
Canada tonight is this gorgeous pink sky
above Norris Point Newfoundland and
Labrador until tomorrow take care of
yourselves and each other good night
[Music]